Hello, everyone.
Hello, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for being late.
I literally was about to start and then I got the email about the
VTuber Marvel Rivals thing.
I was just like, oh, okay, let me look through this.
And I was just like, I got really worried because like I want this tournament to like go well, you know?
I don't know.
I was just, because there's only two tank players in this tournament.
And, like, there's a lot of people that are like, I can off-roll.
Because it's like, first choices.
Like, what's your main role?
And then they're like, okay, but what's your off-roll then?
So, you know, obviously, some of these players can off-roll.
But, you know, I can say I can off-roll as DPS.
But my off-roll as DPS is, like, plat.
Or some shit.
So it's not like, you know, I hit E-turn.
as support but then if I try to off-roll and I barely play off-roll too so there's like some people that do play tank as an off-roll but like I only have one person that does that on my team so I got some I'm like well I see some teams they do have off-rolls for tank there's one team that has zero tank players I'm worried about them I don't know maybe they'll surprise me maybe they don't need a tank player they'll just they'll just like actually no they have okay actually they have one it's like DPS and tank I think they'll just like maybe they'll they have like and they have an insane DPS player who needs a tank if you have an insane DPS player to be fair um and but There is one team that has like three,
four off-rollers who can play tank.
So, like, uh, so there's that.
So it's like, I'm like, it's, it's really sad that we don't have any B-Tuber tank players, which is understandable because who the fuck wants to play tank?
I won't reveal, like, I, it's like, there's some people here that will be very surprised that are participating here.
So I won't reveal who the people are, um, um, that are participating.
Um.
and like I'll let you guys when it's revealed you guys would know the thing is I'm like scared because I do want this to be go well and like balancing is the hardest part but there's no fucking vtuber tank players I'm so not surprised because who wants to play tank it is actually like you gotta be a masochist to want to play fucking tank anyway so I was assigned captain but my concern like I'll be like you know I'll be like super um straightforward with you guys I'll be very transparent guys I don't want to be a captain I think I have to be because like in my head if you're assigned captain um um and if you're assigned captain it means like you know you have like because it's it's a pre-assigned team and um it's a pre-assigned team so i'm like why do we why do i have to be captain i know it's like it's just a title but i don't want the responsibility especially if it's a pre-assigned team i don't like responsibility if i if i have no say in in what happened so yeah so i did Email
asking can I like give up my captain spot because I don't feel come.
I honestly, I just don't feel comfortable being a captain Um, I just don't feel comfortable being captain if there's no captain duties You know what I'm saying like I just I just wanted like like if there's no actual captain dude like I'm not drafting for players I'm not making the team It's just a name.
So I'm like, it's possible if I just, I don't want, because like, if anything happens to my team, people be like, Jokey Brain, and I just don't want that.
I don't want that.
If we get last place, they'll be like, oh, Jokey Brain.
I'm like, no.
I don't want, don't, don't leave your name out of your mouth.
Leave my name out of your mouth.
I've got nothing to do with this.
I don't know.
Matthew, Esther, thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you.
So humble.
We need a captain to keep it.
So that's like, sorry.
That's why I was late.
Because I was like asking like, can I give up my captain's spot?
I don't know.
Maybe there's just be like, no.
And I'll be like, okay.
I don't know.
You know, it doesn't hurt to ask it.
You know, it doesn't hurt to ask if it's okay.
But I don't know.
I feel like I feel like I'm still going to be captain.
But I'm just worried.
You know, I always get like super paranoid about these tournaments.
It's like a double-edged sword.
Because like there's so many support players.
I feel like.
was like saying like um what i'm worried about is that they think i haven't even played the new season yet i haven't even played gambit i think if i was gambit maybe i can carry but the thing is it it's considered a four fun tournament but the literally first place is 7.5k thousand dollars like 7.5k dollars that's like even though it's four fun you know it's still a lot of money So it's not per person,
obviously.
It's divided by six.
But like, you know, everyone wins.
Every team, every, I mean, you have to.
You have to have prize money.
Like you can't, it's hard to make a for fun tournament, but also like make it fun for people to watch as well.
You know, because it's sponsored by Marvel Rivals.
It is sponsored by, you can't really blame them on that because like, you know, it puts more stake into it.
And it is sponsored by Marvel Rivals.
So of course you're going to like, you know, you know, put in sponsor money into the, like put a prize pool and everything because it's officially sponsored by them.
And it's like, you know, it helps motivate to people to, so it's hard.
You can't really, um, it's hard to make it for fun.
Like, you know, my apex tournament had prize money too.
And obviously people took it very seriously as well.
Um, you know, I was trying to push the for fun angle on it, but you know, that's why I tried to balance it with like, you know, fun game modes where you don't really require aim, but it's hard to get people to participate if you don't have prize money and everything so it makes sense like you know you want to put more cred to your tournament so it makes sense to have to have a prize pool it like these tournaments always makes me so fucking scared and paranoid because like I don't know how it's gonna go cuz like I'm like first when I first looked at it I was like this seems pretty hard to balance cuz I'm like I don't know if this is unbalanced or not like I can see some teams that felt like maybe you swap a play like one or two players maybe it'll be better but like it's so hard to balance because 80 i think like 70 of the players okay it's one percent tank players if i'm being um honest it's one percent tank players 70 percent support players and um the rest are dps um and that is
already very hard to balance if you have that percentage of the 1%
you guys are gonna know I'm gonna notice because like a lot of people are gonna be off rolling right now like for this tournament um um Ultron is fucking bad right now guys Ultron's bad like it's all about Gambit it's all about whoever it's all if my team can play dive we would fucking roll everyone that's all I'm gonna say it might My team,
the thing is, I don't know if my team can play dive.
I don't know.
Like, it's either dive or mag.
But I haven't even tried out the new season, you know?
I don't know.
So, that's why I'm like, I'm so nervous.
Like, I hate being so nervous.
I was like so excited to be part of the, you know, the VTuber Cup.
I'm also like really really nervous because you know I don't that's why I don't want to be captain because there's so much uncertainty so I feel weird being captain because I'm like I don't know this is this is I don't know I think there's is like just from my experience looking at like knowing the gameplay of some of these players on here and like knowing like their skill level I feel like there is one team I know which team is gonna be first place it's not my team but other than that like that's the only team I know that's gonna be first place because they have a one above all DPS player um and that's the thing that's so hard to balance because like the only other one above all player is me but also i haven't i'm support
it's like it's so scary because it's like what can i do they play if they they play sidelog what can i do like i can't solo a one above all sidelog player like i'm just i'm just a little guy I mean, maybe with Gambit, but like I said, I haven't even played the new season yet.
Yeah, I'm just gonna heal real hard.
No, you can't, no, no, I will say it's easier to solo carry on DPS as in Marvel Rivals than it is in Overwatch.
In Overwatch, a lot of characters are more like, it's very hard to solo carry.
Back then, in Overwatch, you can solo carry a game easily.
Like, you can just play Widowmaker and hit, like, like, kill four people and then you win.
But now it's not.
Now it's a lot harder because all the tanks have 5,000 HP.
So it's a lot harder now.
Yeah, back then, you can do, like, you know, you can do Nanoblade and then bam, easy.
Or, like, Bayblade with Reaper and a Nanobust.
But now it's not like that.
Even if you have a Mercy Pocket, it's not that easy anymore in Overwatch.
in rivals however it is very easy to solo carry as a dps all the way to celestial maybe even eternity honestly to eternity it's so easy if you have one pocket support on um and just gives you a snowflake or even a mantis damage boost or anything you can solo carry as a dps all the way to eternity um it's just that like it's like um as someone has played this it's like honestly like very easy to do now um especially because the reason why um that's not solo yeah but it's still it's okay duo maybe but you can still do it if you don't even have a pocket you still do it without the pocket you just need to know good players will know where all the health packs are located and because they know where all the health packs are located um they don't have to have a pocket support as long as they can know where the health packs are they can easily like as like flankers or maybe even hella honestly like i had games where i was like you know you guys have seen it before where i would play hella and
then i'd be in like fucking plat or gold elo and i don't play hella a lot and this was a long time ago and i was like playing hella and i literally like just killed pop pop pop headshot headshot headshot everyone's dead we go in like doesn't matter
that don't position very well and then just go pop pop headshot two headshots they're dead and that's like yeah so like you can just click heads and and yeah it's just point and click that's the thing that's why like i'm most nerve like worried about most nervous but i'm trying to be like it's okay just just come down dokey it's it's for fun i just don't want to be captain i i don't want the responsibility of being captain.
But the thing is, I'm also a support player.
I don't really want to off-roll.
I'm not here to off-roll, too.
I just want to play support.
That's really it.
So, I don't know.
I don't know.
I think the teams are honestly going to say the same.
I think at best, if I could, just like, I just don't want the name of Calf.
I just don't want the title.
So, like, you know, if we get last place at least they won't be like dokeybird like team dokeybird in fourth place because i i'd rather just like i like i would be on the team that's last place but please don't call my name out like just just don't call my name out like bro come on it's just it's a title come on i didn't even know i was gonna be captain you know what i just found out i was gonna be captain like like An hour ago!
I just, yeah, I just, I just don't like it.
It's just more like PTSD and trauma for me.
I just, I don't know.
It's just like, it's just like PTSD, I guess.
Like, I just don't like it.
It just gives me like, oh.
As long as team has fun, it shouldn't matter, right?
The thing is, you can, I know like people are like, oh, it's not a team that's have fun, but Marvel Rivals is a hero shooter and like if one team is like a lot weaker than the other I don't know if this is balanced I can't tell so like I'm like I believe I believe in the balancing team because this is very hard to balance me looking at the me looking at the rules and um looking at the rules of what they have to you know work with it is definitely very hard to balance so i can understand like if they've been like trying to struggle trying to fucking find like um the best way to do this um and uh but yeah no like if there is a huge difference in skill level between teams obviously you can't really have fun if you're getting spawn camps someone said so like that's why like you know i'm glad i don't i'm not like you know i i'm glad i'm not in to do this because like I even like I'm like being like I don't know this is balanced I sent my email but like um if anything is it possible I'm just
not the captain like and it's just like even I don't know because it's it's like I'm I'm like, how do you balance this?
Like,
like, uh, yeah, no, getting, no, if you, no, okay, you know what's the most tilting thing?
Getting killed by the same person five times in a row.
I don't want my team to feel that.
Like, I, I don't want my team to feel that, you know, like being killed by the same person five plus times in a row.
That's not fun.
Yeah.
so like and i feel bad you know the thing i feel bad about is that um the thing that i feel the most bad about is that obviously they're like oh joki you've been top 500 before but that was like you know i even wrote like it was the early season like season zero to one i've been top 500 before And it's because of that peak that I,
like, pull up my team's average because of it.
So they have to find weaker, you know, lower ranked teammates to balance it out.
So I feel really bad because all I can do is play support.
I don't even care.
Like, they're like, people, if I play ranked, they'll be like, do you play anything else?
And I'd be like, no.
Be like, no, you swap.
You know, I'm stubborn.
I don't fucking want to play anything else.
Like, so like, I haven't even touched the other roles in a very long time, so...
I'm like, I don't care.
I'm just gonna, I'm still gonna play support.
I'll be like, and then they'll be like, oh, can you play tank?
I have zero hours in tank.
I can just say that.
And then they're like, okay, well, okay.
I, yeah.
Yeah, I have fun with support.
I do.
I enjoy.
I enjoy playing support in Rivals.
Um, so, yeah, um, I'm just nervous.
I'm really nervous about this event.
Ah, ah, I'm nervous.
I really am.
Um, uh, okay, wait, give me a sec.
Let me, oh, I don't mind if it's anyone in my team.
All right, here we go.
All right, um, No, I don't want to flex.
Because the thing is, when you're flexing, it has to be on tank.
And I don't fuck with that.
It's never DPS.
You can never flex on DPS because there's like 200 plus DPS players on my team.
It's never...
When you're flexing, it's never DPS.
It's tank.
I don't want that.
I will never be a tank player.
You can never get that out of me.
Also, am I lagging a little bit with my flex?
it i can't tell i never yeah it's never a dps flex you know it also for those who don't know we didn't get nominated for uh marvel revvo streamer um i did cry i did cry a bit when because like i i stayed i like uh my managers like do work i was like no i'm watching them announce the nomination and then i got i was like ha ha i was so confident you know i was like oh my god silly dokey never go in with high expectations never go in with high expectations joki and then um i was so i was like hopeful and confident because i was like truly i'd get nominated right i was like i don't know i don't know why i thought i'd get a nominated uh that i was like getting ready to screenshot it on my phone as well because i was like i can't get work done uh to my manager because i was like i'm too busy like i have to know like it was like one hour before the stream and it had to wait
forgot that flesh tubers um when not even flesh to but i think like twitch streamers for twitch streamers i'm so used to just like going live after my intro like i loop like two to three times sometimes you know you get like two or three loops and then i swap um and and you know like even then i was like oh your wait guys are waiting too long in the waiting like waiting screen but i forgot that like not just flesh toers but like twitch streamers um they're waiting can be like an hour long before the actual stream like i forgot people do that on twitch um not just like i said i've seen vtubers do it too they would like you know they want people to gather in first but i would like you know the stream started i waited i think like 40 plus minutes like 40 plus minutes before they started the stream um like because it was like starting stream you know the intro stream like the waiting like the starting stream title thing and then i waited 40 minutes and then they uh and then they started
announcing the nomination so i was obviously so antsy and everything um and so like you know i got i was like i got my phone ready to screenshot it and then i was like after the fifth name called i knew i wasn't gonna be in it after i heard the fifth name i was like i no i didn't make it i so then i obviously i started I just thought that,
you know, like, you know, people were like, oh, why are you so, why are you so like, um...
Put so much into this, like, oh, it's just a meaningless award.
The thing is, I put a lot of effort campaigning for it.
So, like, you know, and then it's like... I thought it'd be really cool, and it'd be really nice to be like, you know, a VTuber representative, because you don't see VTubers nominated outside of...
see vtubers nominated outside of like the vtuber category so um so that's why like that's why i put so much like you know um expectations on myself for it and i thought this was like oh yeah this is like one of the categories that vtubers have a chance to like shine in because like i did so much on my rivals as a vtuber and like marvel sponsors me a lot in like uh sponsors me a lot for like their stuff and um you know they usually just pick me on the vtuber side and it's all flesh tubers um so you know i thought i you know i was like oh maybe there's a possibility there's a chance um and so that's why like you know i thought it'd be really cool i was like oh that'd be such good like representation you know be like look see a vtuber can like get on this category as well like get outside of the vtuber category because it doesn't happen very often like um i know like IRLS,
she has got nominated various things outside of either category, and it puts a lot of exposure to VTubers in general, because, you know, it's a normie.
Lots of normies watch this, like, the people that are nominated, also, like, it's the meta for streaming changed so much, it's mostly IRL streaming, it's crazy.
But, like, you know, it's also, like, you know, a lot of normies, and, like, you know, watch the streamer awards, and, like, especially, like, the good publicity in general um so that's why you know i felt really bad i felt really sad because i was like oh i can't believe i can i was like oh my gosh oh like you know i was like oh why did i thought i could do it like because you know i know a lot of it's not your guys fault i just think that you know youtubers are still um a niche it's like a huge niche and honestly i feel like it's more So,
like, oh, it's not because, like, okay, that's what pissed me off the most.
What the thing was pissing me off the most was that people on my tweets, you know, of course, you know, all my tweets being like, my community didn't show up or, like, your community just didn't vote for you.
And I was like, that's a fucking lie.
I know so many dragoons have voted me.
And I know a lot of, like, VTubers from different, um, a lot of VTubers outside of my circle were saying, no, vote for a dokeybird for Marvel rivals.
So I was like, there's, it's not my community.
not showing up.
It's not like, even the VTuber, like, the VTuber community even voted for me in Marvel Revivals.
Like, it wasn't just my community, too.
So, it's just because this is my theory.
It's just that, because I am not part of, like, I'm not, like, a normie streamer, and we're, like, VTubers, you know, like, it's still niche.
We're still very niche.
We're part of a niche group within a niche group, because we're part of the anime group, and then within the...
And the thing is, like, a lot of these Normie streamers, like, Normie viewers, they'll be like, I don't know anyone in Marvel Rivals, but, hey, this guy, I've seen this guy play this game once, and he collabs with the streamer that I do like, and I know he plays Marvel Rivals,
so I'm gonna vote for him.
I think it's just that.
They're just, like, you know, they're voting for their favorite norm, like, they're voting for their favorite blush tuber and they got to the Marvel rival categories and they'll be like I remember this oh yeah this guy this guy played with um this guy played with my favorite streamer one time and it was Marvel Rivals or like and I don't remember he she's Marvel Rivals I'm gonna vote for him too like I don't know what he actually does but I'm gonna vote for him because you know he he's like my favorite streamer's friend or like he he uh he's collabed with my favorite streamer and uh he so it's just that and and it's just like you know but obviously I don't know a lot of flesh tubers uh so obviously like and like flesh like a lot of flesh tuber viewers a lot of normies they don't really watch vtubers so it's just basically that I just think I just don't have the reach and I don't stream on Twitch that often too I know a lot of people are like oh you should do multi-streaming now you know
like hololab is doing multi-streaming now um but like i feel so okay i don't know i know like i'm like i'm like um stagnating my growth by not streaming on twitch um and i know that i know i'm stagnating my growth by being so stubborn and splitting you know like doing twitch as an streams but like i hate the chat restrictions i hate it so much and like i saw like apparently also the rules are so um unclear because i saw like i saw someone i don't remember who it was it was a while ago that was like trying to warn the hollow live girls being like don't keep your don't keep two twitch chat don't keep youtube and twitch chat on the stream or like you could get banned and so poorly written you can apparently have both twitch chat streams on like both chats on your screen but they have to be divided like i don't know like they gotta be segregated like they cannot touch it's crazy so you can have both chats and they just can't touch they have to be on opposite sides of the screen yeah it's
fucking weird i
yeah so you have to have but and it can't be like you know like a little space between them it has to be actually like on the other side like it's so so because everyone thought that you can't have youtube chat on if you're doing multi-streaming on twitch but apparently the rules are so because that was like everyone would parrot that it'd be like everyone was parrots it and was like yeah um you can't have like you can't have them like like uh have both on the screen you only can only have twitch chat because like twitch will ban you if you have youtube chat on the screen because that's how vague the rules are that's how vague it is and um uh and then i found like No,
no, you can't have both chats.
They just can't be together.
They just have to be, like, very clearly separated so that you can't have them there.
Also, someone was like, oh, what about there's some streamers that have them merged.
Those streamers have a contract with Twitch that allows them to do that.
Because they don't want them to leave their platform.
So they have a contract where they can merge their chats.
um but they're very very picky on who gets that contract uh so um so there are some creators on twitch that can merge it but if you aren't like you know you're not one of those creators that have that contract obviously you can't do it um it's you know it's makes sense because like you don't want the streamer with 30 000 viewers leave your platform like like you want it to go to
no it's not just chat it's more so of like you know in the contractors a lot of like stipulations and a lot of like rules that you can bypass because you're like oh i want if you want me on your platform um you want me to stream on your platform like i'll do this and i would like this and this and this um because like i say i that's the one reason why i don't want to multi-stream because it's like it's ugly i don't want to have both chats on opposite sides of the screen It's so I would be like okay I mean if I could do something where like you know This this is like tiny like you know the YouTube chat is here And then the Twitch chat is like right under there Like that's fine I'm fine with that But the fact that I do two different chats on like different It's just it's screen color there I hate screen color there I just hate it like It just doesn't look good I mean I
No, it has to be, you have to be like, like very clearly separated and everything.
It's just, oh, that's what I hate.
That's what I hate.
I just like, they have to be like here and then the other one will have to be like very clearly not touching each other.
And I just, oh, it pisses me off.
There are a lot of years that do what you just said.
It's not allowed, though.
It's not, I was reading that thread.
I won't say it, but like, no snitching, no snitching though.
But I was reading that thread and people were saying, it's just, it's just more so like, as long as Twitch doesn't do anything to you, um, if one is going up and one is going, they can't touch as one is going up and one is going down.
Those are so fucking unclear.
I was reading the Twitter thread and I was looking at like, hololive.
And they didn't want to, like, get in trouble.
So they separated it in two different sides.
It's not so...
I was reading a thread and people were saying it's not supposed...
They can't touch.
People were saying that, too.
And, like, that's what I'm saying.
It's so unclear.
It's so fucking unclear.
Because, like, the...
And I know, like, you know, I don't want to fuck with Twitch.
They're so unclear.
I feel like the rules need to be more clarified because I was reading the thread about it and then um and like people were saying that like yeah like they're not supposed to touch and I'm like okay but like even before then even before then it was like common knowledge where like twitch was like you can't you can't have youtube chat on stream on screen like i was like uh that's what they i just don't like having two chats on my screen because of the clutter it's just it already covers so much you know i play video games i do a lot of gaming streams um and like and like the thing is i try to minimize as much clutter as possible and i don't like that like the fact that you know twitch like the chat can having two chats can cover a lot up a lot of stuff yeah one chat is fun but having two it covers a lot of stuff that's on the screen when i already have myself on screen as well like no it's just because like you know that's what also is really hard about being a vtuber streamer it's
because if you're doing like if you're a fleshtuber you can just shrink your uh you can just shrink your cam and stuff but like you know a lot of people like watching vtuber streamers for the vtuber on the screen and then that's already covering up like one fourth of the game and and then it's like oh yeah it's just uh just shrink yourself like What's the point?
I might as well not be on screen.
It's like those, like, I shrink myself and I'm like those like interpreter, like the hand sign interpreter people are like right on the bottom.
This will just shrink myself.
I'd be like, like the interpreter.
I'm doing my hand signs and doing like, oh, this is what she's saying.
Your ASL dokey right here.
uh but yeah i know i should multi-stream i know i just i don't know i should suck up my integrity and pride i just wish the rules aren't so unclear because it's like now i'm finding out that apparently you can have uh both chats touch each other but like people were like arguing against that i was reading it up i was like oh uh because he can't look like it's merged so so it's like what if like are these rules that are actually like if twitch doesn't like you they'll give you like a suspension like stuff like that like i you know okay someone okay someone earlier was saying that um someone earlier uh when i streamed on twitch they were saying uh uh that like oh dokey you changed the description on your twitch because in my old description i was like i stream on youtube more follow me there and then when i found out holla i was doing multi streams i was gonna do multi streams on twitch or like not multi stream was joining twitch i had to read the guidelines um this was the same day i
saw someone tweeting out like trying to warn the hollow girls being like don't merge your chats or anything or don't have both chats on screen because that's against the rules which apparently isn't anymore like What the fuck?
Like, no.
Why are the rules so unclear?
Like, so then I reread the rules again.
Um, I reread the rules.
And, um, and then I found out you're not supposed to advertise a different platform to encourage viewers to come to that platform.
And I realized I've been breaking the rules for a very long time.
So I quickly changed it.
That
was the day I changed the description.
Because in there, it was like, you're not supposed to encourage.
other your viewers to come come follow you on it I quickly changed it because I was like oh fuck okay I no and you didn't get punished for it I think I sort of did because one of the twitch staff unfriended me on discord and unfollowed me on Twitter they're just like I don't want to deal with you
so yeah but that was a long time ago no it was before it was before like yeah it was it was a while ago I just didn't realize it until like a couple like a month or two ago I realized it because like my manager asked me something about like oh you have a twitch staff I could message about something and I was like yeah let me look up and I was like wait I can't find them discord friends list so so um no no they're still working there i think i saw their twitter so i was just like oh let me no problem let me find them on my discord friends list and i was like wait they're not my friends list anymore and i was like wait are you still following me on twitter i was like oh they're not following me on twitter anymore so i was like um
that's awkward um i was like well i found their discord handle but um they removed me on discord so i don't know if they can help you for anything so uh so um good good luck uh uh um next see thank you for the super chat thank you thank you for what it's worth i do appreciate you just stream on youtube it's comfy but i won't blame you decide to dual stream i don't know i don't know i just i don't like um i personally just i'm not a fan of dual streaming but i know it i'm stagnating my growth by not dual streaming because like i said you know twitch is for any like english speaking streamers um youtube is more for um for like um you know for live streams it's more geared towards Asia um Twitch is for EU and NA and YouTube is for bots like it's for video uploads short form content it's not really for live oh my god okay so I was talking to Moxie and he was like oh he was like check he's like sharing screen with me and he's like I was like yeah no I she's like oh you don't I don't see on
Twitch often I was like like went on YouTube went onto my channel and was like you don't have a lot of uploads I was like no you fucker it's on click live and he's like that's a thing that's a tab I was like oh my god you fucking yeah you go straight to videos because like that's what people normally do and it's like wait what there is a tab called for live like live I'm like yes you fuck That's my main platform.
Yeah, a lot of people don't know about YouTube live.
Mine is fucking blown.
Yeah, like.
So, so that, and it's a lot of people that don't know that.
A lot, especially a lot of normies that don't know that there is a live tab on YouTube.
Um, so, so that's why I know, I'm, I know I'm not like, I'm stunting my growth, but I hate it.
I hate it.
I hate the new meta is about these streaming because people are like, you, you, you know, are like, you are, you are not fucking over your career.
You are more so like, you are not taking advantage.
of the things of the things like the materials in front of you by uh by not multi-streaming and it's like ah I hate splitting viewerships too I hate it I hate it so much um I just want you know I just don't want to split viewerships too I just want everyone to be here with me in one area
I am a meta slave, though.
That's the worst part.
I'm a meta slave.
Let's see.
There is a fundamental brand where people have brand loyalty.
This is about the only noticeable difference.
Magic, thank you.
Super Chat, thank you.
Thank you.
Crunch, thank you.
The Super Chat, thank you.
Thank you.
You're my favorite Marvelized streamer.
You inspired me as I've been in emotional slump.
And my room is cluttered.
I took your advice and started day by day.
Thank you.
I'm happy that, you know, you're taking the steps to feel better.
yourself really does mean a lot uh to help you with that um but yeah no like i said uh to go back with the whole mara rava's thing i i mentioned i hated that like like you know the randoms were like you know blaming you guys it was fucking pissed me off like i didn't care i like after the you know not knowing knowing that i didn't get nominated i literally played fortnite through two hours later like i i was okay you know i was sad you know as i should be because like um I did spend a lot of time campaigning.
I spent a lot of time campaigning.
And I also did bonus streams late at night.
You know, when I was already so busy.
I was already so busy.
And I did do bonus rival streams late at night.
So it wasn't like I didn't try.
I think I felt like I did try.
And so obviously, you know, that's why people are like, why are you so sad about this meaningless award why are you like because i put so much time and effort even though you guys might some of you guys might think it's meaningless i still you know i still put effort into trying to campaign so it you know in my in my head i feel like oh i've wasted so much time i could have if i knew like you know it wasn't possible i wouldn't have you took that time
you know like so that's why i didn't think you i personally didn't think it's meaningless i thought like you know um it was it would have been nice to you know be able to have a vtuber outside of the vtuber category um in one of those spots um and then okay another thing that i felt like i was getting rage baited um was that um like people were like oh someone was like you didn't even tweet about it that's a fucking lie someone that was following me i i held my tongue was like i looked at her twitter and she didn't even tweet about uh um asking for a vote if anything my tweet had the most likes out of all the nominees that asked for a vote so don't fuck with me right because vtuber fans love Twitter they love interacting with Twitter normies for some reason don't I was like normies don't interact with Twitter but VTuber fans fucking love interacting with Twitter don't fuck with me yeah like and then someone else that that um yeah because we're chronically online because that's how we
fucking were able to interact with our favorite anime person like real normies maybe they'll go out the street and be like oh my god there's there's kaisenad walking in target you can catch them but you know how only we can see our favorite anime girl or boy online so we have to be chronically online like
He can look outside and then you'd be like, oh my god, there's speed doing his running shit.
I don't fucking know.
Like
And then another thing, another thing that, um, um, that like fucked with rage baited me, but I, but I had to say it because i was like i know i'm like oh i'm fine i'm like after that but i have to talk about it was that uh i remember reading not even just one person multiple people were like oh it's just because you didn't stream enough marva rivals all the other nominees um um streamed more than you and i was just like okay and then i was like don't oh don't pull that card if anything half the nominees streamed it when they were sponsored.
Don't fuck with me.
Like, and like, I won't say half.
Maybe like, like one or two.
And then like, I know like one, another one, they like, basically, they like, um, they, they stream it.
They do stream it, but they don't like stream it.
They are variety.
One or two of them are just variety and rivals is their variety stream.
You know who else does that?
you know I'm considered a variety streamer but I do stream rivals a lot as well I even play rivals off stream so I was like you cannot so like I'm just like oh my god like when I saw like several people's commenting that I was like no you do know that didn't know me being a variety streamer doesn't fucking put me out of the running because I still consistently stream rivals outside of being sponsored.
But they're like implying that like the nominees weren't also variety streamers?
Like I was like, if anything I think Bougar's the only pure rival streamer in the nominations.
So I was just like, I was just like, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm pretty sure like three of them have the same consistency as me in terms of like variety and streaming rivals.
So that's why I was just like, um that's why i was like you can't use that argument for me
i even play off stream like i'm just like bro i that's how i'm like bro i'm so i'm in so deep i play off stream like have you ever seen tim play off stream bro he has a family to take care of he's not fucked up like me like
he has a life outside like he ain't fucked up like me I play off I play rivals at three in the morning off stream I ain't here to make content out of it I actually just purely enjoy the game like I purely enjoy the game so much that I will not sleep to play rivals at three in the morning I have a problem please understand like
He's very healthy.
Yo, I had so many people.
I bumped into...
While I was playing off stream, not at a degenerate hour.
Actually, at like, you know, 12 p.m.
or some shit.
Like, 12 or 1 p.m.
I bumped into...
What's his name?
The org that left.
By the way, 100 Thieves left the Marvel Rivals.
Didn't leave the Marvel Rivals.
For those who do follow Esports, 100 Thieves didn't leave the Marvel Rivals scene.
They're just they just didn't want to pay I think they just didn't want to play paid a roster before the new league was announced because if they still have Here's a little like esport like knowledge for you guys like business knowledge like Net ease slash rivals haven't announced the new league yet but there's no tournaments until 2026
org because that's you know they're all losing money you know like majority of esports orgs aren't making money um and you know you know they don't want to pay their teams it's you know they have to pay them monthly you know so it's easier to not to kick you know to drop their team and wait until the 2026 league is announced and then recruit a new team That's at least four months of not paying wages.
Like, so that's why they dropped their team.
Because why the fuck would they pay the roster money when there's no tournaments to enter?
Like, it's messed up.
But esports orgs are not making money.
Except for, like, that 1%.
I think the only, I'm pretty sure, um, the, the, the, the only esport org that I'm very confident in, that is making an actual profit is T1.
Purely off of Faker.
That's it.
That's the only esport org that full confidence is making actual income.
And, and.
Nothing else I feel like I feel like I feel like T1's the only org Um Um So yeah So anyway Back to my story Uh Back to my story Uh I was like 12 to 1 p.m.
And um Uh Uh
let's see oh yeah i'm not captain thank god
yeah i don't get to be capped sorry no i just got the message they're like you don't have to be captain like thank god i don't i don't care they're like oh it'd be more publicity if you're like Team Doki brand.
I don't care Me already being in that team everyone knows who I am I don't need to be like you don't have to like push my name out there Like anyone that's watching for Marva rivals already knows my name.
It's fine Like I'm that much of a degenerate for this game like on the VTuber side.
I think everyone's aware Yay dodging responsibility.
Yeah
I just don't want them to be like, oh, Team Doki Braid, Lost.
I just don't want people to say that.
Like, I'm just here for the ride.
I don't want to be on the driver's seat.
Anyway, my story, my story.
Basically,
Uh, uh, so I bumped into, who is it?
Delena.
Sorry, I was like, do I remember the name?
I was like, one of the PS players.
It was like, is I heard Delena or Terra?
But I remember it was Delena.
Um, because he's the, uh, because I remember it was Delena.
Anyway, I bumped into Delena in rank.
Also, me, thank you for the 20 gift of ships.
Thank you, thank you.
And, um, I was like, Oh, oh, and in Delena, I was, I pulled up his stream.
He's part of a hundred thieves.
For those who don't follow esports, he is part of a hundred thieves, and they are known as the best team in NA, but they got fourth.
Was it third?
Or it was, was it third or fourth?
I don't remember.
They are the best team in NA.
But, you know, EU fucked NA hard.
So it doesn't matter because EU fucked NA.
a challenge too that's the worst part like i was so ahead of na like it was not even it was so sad it wasn't even a goddamn challenge like it was just three oh done like oh sorry um all right oh fly quest was the okay but under these one first in the na tournament um but In the world,
land, they were fourth place.
Black Quest got third because meta favored them.
Because the thing is, for those who don't follow Marvel Rivals meta, I'm sorry.
I'm info dumping you guys so hard.
People are like, I don't care about Marvel Rivals.
But this entire stream was one hour of me talking about Marvel Rivals.
But basically, the thing is, after the NA tournament, meta, like, they had to play on the new season patch.
So because of they had to play on the new season patch, the meta from the NA tournament fully shifted in the world tournament so they only had i think like one month to prep for the new meta so like you know that's not a lot of time so they had one month to learn the entirely new meta i think was less than that was it like only three weeks it was like two to three weeks maybe yeah it was like two to three weeks between not even one month it was like two to three weeks to learn an entire new meta with a new with some new hero pools maybe like not you know your tanks or dps or supports not their strongest hero pools um going into the one million dollar land um because how's that different than the others because it may dive a lot stronger the new meta made dive so fucking strong because for those who don't know the new meta was that they buffed venom for those who forgot they heavily buffed majority of the dive characters and they released daredevil so na has been practicing non-dive for
the entire time but in eu they've always been playing dive So, for them, there was like, you know, it's nothing changed for them in general.
So, in NA, they all don't know how to learn Dive in time in two to three weeks, going in to a $1 million land.
And the best Venom players in the world are all EU players.
That's the thing.
The best Captain America, the best Venom player, the best Angelo player, we're all European.
were the European pros.
So I would say the best non-dive kit, the best, you know, the stationary tanks, you know, the best mag, the best strange, the best Emma, those were NA.
But that doesn't matter.
Yeah, the best captain, captain Europe, basically.
No, captain Europe.
It was literally captain Europe.
So all the best stationary tanks were NA.
And all the best dive tanks were European.
But the $1 million land was literally dive.
Like, it was dive meta.
So, like, they can't.
And the thing is, they're like, oh, why don't you just replace the players in time for the roster's were locked since the beginning.
So it's not like you can poach someone for the million dollar land.
Because the roster is locked before the first tournament.
It was before the first tournament even started.
The regional tournaments, like NA tournament.
European tournament, Asia tournament, the rosters are fully locked.
You can't change the roster until the end of the season, which is after the million dollar world tournament.
So, you know, and it was pretty much fucked.
Like, it was so sad.
I watched the land.
I was so bored.
I'm sorry.
Like, because it was literally, even like the two best European teams, like, it was a 3-1 during, like, first versus second.
that was like because like the best dive players were all on the first place team so I was it was literally like 3-1 and um and like I was just like okay it was so it was one-sided as hell like it was not like it was like it was so fucking one-sided there was no actual fight like you know who's if the second place team even put up much of a fight like the saddest part was there was no fight there was no actual like you'll be like fight back no they're dead like not like half of them are in a coma right now and half are like dead like so so anyway back to my original story now explain sorry you guys needed a con you guys didn't need the context of you fucking n a hard but like i just wanted to tell you guys like what it was like and what it might be like too um
um um anyway back to my original story of like how much of a degenerate i am um um i bumped into delena who's his 100 thieves and i pulled up his snow because they were streaming he was streaming with like another pro player uh but they were both solo because you know like like i'd say it's such a weird twitch meta now where like even though you're not streaming streaming together like you're actually you're not like playing together a lot of the smaller streamers they do the stream together just so they can combine all their viewerships together to be on the top of the twitch page and twitch category is very smart but it fucks with commute interaction i think it's smart but also the downside of it is that like you get no community and you don't get a community because you're not interacting with chat because everybody's chat is combined so how the fuck are you gonna read your own chat then like you know your chat has to read everyone else's chats too so you're not building your
community but um it's not cynical because like how can you you know how can you build your community if you don't have your community um so um so so like thing is they all combine it too so i don't know why they do they all combine i think they combine it to make their chat look active um you know because they'll be like oh why does it say this much viewership they do it to like make it so their chat uh chat looks very active so um anyway sorry that's not even part of the original story anyway bumped into delena back to the original story and um he like randomly he was like he was i was watching navad because i was like oh hey delena we lost obviously um because like we had someone throwing on our team i don't remember what was going on but you know um i am an e-o-m-m um terrorist so like it like it just follows me so at that point i'm not even like surprised that we had someone throwing anyway um and you realize then elena try to add me uh to invite me to play um because i've never
talked to him before um the one interaction i had was when i also got him in a game on stream and then he started throwing and i was i was like because but before he started throwing sorry this is another tangent you guys might remember the story like remember the stream but i got delena in my game like a long time ago and um i was like look guys it's delena from 100 thieves and delena was like is that the real dokey bird and i said nothing and then he swapped the squirrel girl and started throwing and i was like guys i should have told him i am the real dokey bird like i was like him so he wouldn't throw like and then i think and then he realized i was the real bogeybird and then he like he like swat back to um he swat back to like a real dps character uh and then that was my and then he went into my chat and was like we should play together so now i was like yeah sure add me and that was like four months ago so that was like the last interaction that was the only first and only
interaction I've had with Delano.
Anyway, fast forward to like last week, bumped into him again.
And then obviously I wasn't streaming because I play for the love of the game, not because I want to just make, like, you know, just not because I want to have to stream it or anything.
I actually enjoy playing this game off stream.
I looked at his chat because after the game, I looked at his chat and then I was, I was AFK and I came back and then I saw his chat wanted to see like, oh, did you say anything?
Did he notice I was in his game?
And, um, and, um, in the chat, they're like, oh, Doki Bird, uh, Doki Bird, uh, what is it called?
What's that lingo people use nowadays when, oh, don't know Waldo.
I was like, what does that Twitch lingo?
Um, they're like, wow, I can't believe Doki Bird don't know Waldo.
Or like, yeah, she doesn't acknowledge you, bro.
And I was like, what?
I was so confused.
I was like, what the fuck?
I didn't They didn't even ask me.
They didn't even say anything to me.
And apparently, Don't Know What Means like, they, like, try to talk to you, but you ignore them.
So, like, so they don't talk, like, you don't talk to them until you don't.
I think it's like they don't talk to you.
They're, like, trying to imply that they don't acknowledge you unless you give money to them.
I think that's what that means.
And you know that I don't Don't Know What, you guys, because I'm literally interacting with all of you guys, and I don't have a super chat right now.
yeah yeah guys no one super chatted me and i still talk to you guys all right i still read a comment in the chat uh so i don't know walling also thank you for the rage thank you thank you we had a great stream and so also next thing thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
um anyway so um what happened was that and i re-watched the vod and he was like wait is that dokeyberry the real one and then he was like asking his friend he was like yo was she streaming right now and then he was like nah she offline and he was like what the they were like what the They were like,
what the fuck, why is she like, bro, she played for the love of the game, bro.
They were like, they couldn't comprehend the fact that I was playing off stream.
They were like, like, funky freak.
Like, bro, you think she plays her fun, bro?
Like, so my viewers, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Let me fix that for you.
Lord Corrosus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's ridiculous.
You miss super chats all the time and we love you anyway.
Yeah, I'm the reverse dono, Walter.
I'm wall dono.
I don't know.
Um, Patroesu, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, I play because I have a problem.
Quick throw, Mule is super chats to smoke screen here.
Mr. Broken ball.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Please notice me.
All I have is five dollars.
always.
Link, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
I'm donut walling right now.
Is this what donut walling feels like?
Just reading my super chats.
Don't stop donut walling us.
Thank you for the super chat.
Luke, thank you.
Thank you.
Billy, thank you for the 10 gift that shows.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, it's me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sometimes donut seems to hurt your chances of being noticed.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Patre, too.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anyway, I think that's really all there is about...
Um...
Sorry, I had to reread the message right now.
But that's really all about my rivals.
We're over.
The rivals tangent is done.
What if I just play rivals right now?
But I won't do that to you guys yet.
The big story.
Okay.
okay oh my god i fucking hate my bank i wish i could call them out but i can't yeah because it's a very canadian specific bank oh god i fucking i know like some people if you're a canadian i feel like some guys already sort of know which bank it is because there's only one really fucking terrible canadian bank and i'm definitely okay i'll tell you i'll give you guys this context um my mom picked this bank um because she knew it was a bad bank and like so so like she was like she wanted to take advantage of that and like disgusting and anyway so um I didn't realize how bad of a bank um this particular bank was until all the problems um all the problems showed up handle this like so um you know after i started living on my own and taking back my own business um i really i because i didn't because like my mom handled controlled the banks she controlled the business and um so i didn't realize how bad this bank was until i took retook over my entire um a year or plus ago so and like started
living on my own and then i oh my god i cannot wait for me to leave this bank i oh i'm oh my god okay so anyway i have to go through so much shit no she just took control over the business and my bank like the bank the business bank account uh because she was the one that opened um she was the one that opened um um the business bank account um like she was in charge of it and um and she picked this bank so god i hate this bank by the way i know i keep saying it but bro it's so fucking bad i'm gonna tell you why this new story you guys already know so many stories about this bank um uh ashram thank you for the five gift of ships thank you thing the thing is when i took over the um when i took over this my business again and also the bank accounts um i created a new business bank account under a new business name you know because i wanted to like you know i wanted to go clean slate like you know this is my own business um my parents are not involved in this this is my own and i went with
the same bank because i didn't realize how fucking bad it was because i was like well my parents my mom picked this bank so clearly she knew what she was doing so um i might as well go with the same bank so because There shouldn't be any problems.
I was so fucking wrong.
There were so many problems.
Because I didn't realize how bad it was.
Until I had to take over it.
But it was so late.
I already made a new bank account.
With my new business underneath this particular bank.
But yes.
Some of the Canadians.
Who know about the worst bank in Canada.
know exactly which bank it is because there's only one really bad bank in Canada like one exceptionally terrible bank in Canada and so anyway so today I had to call them because i'm tired of doing wire transfers by going to the branch because every other fucking bank in the world does not require you to go to travel to the branch to do wire transfers um and so i was like obviously uh maybe uh maybe you know i'm gonna call them because like i was talking to my manager about this because like they're like okay you have to pay this person you have to pay that person and i was like and they're like did you pay this person yet i was like no because i have to walk over to the bank um to i have to do like a like a really long walk to the bank to do it and i don't want to do it for one wire transfer so i'm waiting for it to all build up until and then i go there and i just do like four to five wire transfers um at Like,
you know, because I don't want to fucking, you know, just do it one at a time.
So, they're like, what the fuck?
So my match is like, what the fuck?
Because, like, you know, like, he knows it.
He knows I have to do it.
He's like, he still can't, he still can't wrap his head around.
Because I've told this to him multiple times.
But he still can't wrap it around in his head.
that I have to walk over there to do the wire transfer.
And I was like, what, isn't that not how...
Like, when I first told him this, he's like, I was like, isn't that how all banks do that?
And he's like, no.
He's like, no.
What the...
Yeah, in the 70s.
Like, yeah.
He's like, I don't know, in the fucking 70s?
Like, it's 2025.
Like...
so you're like yeah maybe 30 years ago maybe but like not now like everyone's things did it i was like what i was like no that's not true they don't they don't defeat i asked so mid they're like you gotta go to the branch to do your wire transfers and no i'm not talking about e-transverse i meant wire transfer international wire Bansfers that cannot do Online apparently And then like When I pay like Americans Like they were like Just do it online Here's their information And I was like I have to walk to Sorry I have to figure like Oh can you not send the payment Like today I was like No I have to walk to the branch And it's like 9pm now And it's closed And they're like obviously Like my American My American people that pay they're like what the fuck do you mean like just do it online like no i can't do that the bank is closed i can't i can't just like i'm sorry the bank is closed or i'll be like i'm sorry it's sunday so i'm sorry sir it's sunday i can't i i have to wait until after
sunday to go to the bank to do this wire transfer i can't do it it's closed like
so um so anyway uh I was like I like called them today because I was like I can't keep doing this I can't keep walking it to the bank um I can't keep walking to the bank to like make a uh wire transfer like it's just not convenient in or like it's just it's so un it's so unorthodox of him to do so no Canada is so fucking weird with technology they're like they're like I I swear to God there's so much bureaucracy in Canada and like there's so much bureaucracy in Canada and like so many hoops to jump through I feel like I am not living in the 21st century like like it's just canada it's literally just canadian things
so um anyway um so i called i called my mink and now it's just like i called my branch and i was like so i like i really want to like uh want to know like i have to um i have okay i lied by the way i had so i called my bank and i started lying and i was like oh i have to go out of country um in like um in like a month or two and um i have to go to the states and the thing is um um this bank bank branch is gonna be very far away to where i have to where you know where i have to be stationed for my business trip um and i'll be staying there for like a couple of months so i was just wondering if there is a way because if i say like oh i want to do wire transfers why i live close by in canada they'll be like oh i'm sorry ma'am just go to the nearest T.
I'm sorry, a lot of rage came in.
Sorry, just go to the nearest bank branch.
Sorry, I said, just go to the I'm sorry to say the newest bank branch.
And then you'll be fine, because, you know, it's Canada.
It's Canada.
And I said the bank, the Canadian.
bank anyway yeah i was trying to say the bank anyway um anyway just yeah so
as i was saying um so obviously i had to make up a scenario like figure out what the fuck to do for the wide transfer and so sorry my Canadian accent went really strong there um so I was saying like oh like in one to two months I have a business trip where I have to be in the States for a while so I was wondering um like the closest uh bank um like the closest branch of your bank is not that close to me um so i have a lot of important wire transfers i have to make for my business so i was wondering like uh i was what i used to work for this yeah it was bad i it was so bad it's it still is um anyway i was wondering if there is your way to do this wire transfer because i don't want to travel an hour or two away to an hour or two away to do this wire transfer you know obviously but like they'll do like no i just don't want to walk like i just didn't walk like um several walks to this goddamn fucking bank like in general even though the walk is like less than 30 minutes i don't fucking
want to walk there like does no I'm actually still going to be in Canada um anyway so the guy he was like oh we have something called the global money transfer um and you can do that online or on your app and I was like oh really and he was like yeah it's called the global money transfer and um your account should be able to do it and you can do it online and it's really simple just check it up on your app or on your pc and i was like can't be that easy like surely can't be that easy so i was like okay sure all right thank you and then you know stupid me um instead of you know trying it out Dad I ate dinner the the bank is closed I got on my PC and looked for a global money transfer for my bank I logged into my bank account I clicked on the option global money transfer
I see your account is not eligible for global money transfer you are a small business account please go to wire transfer to see how you can do wire transfer and by the way when I call my branch they are very aware that my account is a small business account and they still recommended me global money transfer
so so i'm like thinking why the fuck did you recommended me When you know damn well, my account is not eligible.
So, I don't know.
I don't know what to do.
I don't fucking know what to do.
I don't know.
Maybe I'll call them tomorrow.
I don't fucking know.
By the way...
by the way here's a little other fun fact that my bank told me because I was like oh I'm going to be in the States and like maybe in a month or two for a business trip and they were like oh yeah um we can't really help you when you're in the States by the way man because um our bank in America we have branches there it's not owned by us it's owned by the united states so like it's actually a different um company that operates um our the banks there so like we can't really help you much for your canadian accounts if you're gonna be using the american branch side of our bank and i'm like are you fucking kidding me what what do you mean then why are they called
by the canadian Inside it's owned by the America and it's apparently a fully different or Corporation that runs the American side Like I was like you have the same name and logo Like I was like what do you mean they get so if I go to the American Branch of this particular bank,
they will not be able to assist me on my Canadian accounts because they do not have the, oh my god, what's the word?
They do not have the access to it because they are the American branch side and it's owned by a different corporation.
They don't have the authority to access or the infrastructure to access my account in chat, like my Canadian account.
And I'm like, what?
And then, and then they were like, also, um, ma'am, if, um, if we have to send you anything, like new cards or, uh, They're like, we need to send you anything like new cards or new credit cards or any banking information via mail.
We won't be able to send it to you at your American address or any of the American branches.
Because like we said, we have no affiliation with the American side of our bank because it is owned by a different corporation.
And, um, you'll only be able to pick it up when you're back in Canada.
And I was just like, what if I'm staying there for that?
What am I going to do with my business?
Like, I'm just like, because I'm just like, actual Skinwalker Bay.
So I'm just like, what would I do if I had to, like, go on a business trip for, like, I don't know, half a year, like, in not even just the States, but just, like, somewhere else in the world?
Like, what the fuck am I gonna do?
Like, that's not a big...
I was like, it's so inconvenient.
you know which bank I miss HSBC I miss them I miss HSBC so much they treated me like a queen they oh my god HSBC in a royal bank treated me like a fucking queen oh my god oh because like hsbc got bought by royal bank so they they stopped existing in canada i don't know they're still around i know like majority um majority of the hsbc bank for those who don't know hsbc it's a hong kong uh bank um but majority of HSBC banks in Canada got bought off by Royal Bank and then like my account got transferred to my HSBC account got transferred to the Royal Bank account.
I still have my Royal Bank account but they they treated me like a fucking queen.
Oh my God.
I swear I might just transfer my I might just i might just like whenever i have time i need to move all my funds out and just go to royal bank because it's royal royal big treating me royally like i'm coming back i'm coming back yeah anything will be better than the fuck the fuck i have to deal with anything will be much better
Okay, um Next see Thank you for the super chat Thank you Thank you I would try calling up and asking them to enable the Global transfer for your account Alright, so you're gonna have to change banks My work Thank you the super chat Thank you Thank you I'm gonna call tomorrow When my branch is open About my About the global transfer option Because I was like What do you mean My account's not eligible for global transfer I'm like I was encouraged to use it.
All right.
But, no, it's the Royal Bank of Canada.
I assume that's what the RBC means.
Let me double check.
All right, yeah, Royal Bank of Canada.
I'm willing to call out Royal Bank of Canada because they've always treated me right.
They've never fucked with me.
They've always been so nice to me Like For those who are like wondering like Oh man Like what the fuck is wrong with cat Let me tell you a story About one time I Had to deal I had to deal With Canadian With Canadian airport
this was a long time this was a while ago but it was when um this was a long time ago um when like uh we were trying to like um this was not with dad this was for another like our older other dog And we had to like, we had to like fly us and our dog to like,
I think it was to the States.
No, no.
It was, oh my God, it wasn't even to the states.
It was like somewhere in Canada.
We had to fly to somewhere in Canada and we had to bring our other dog.
And it was a, it was a weaner dog too.
And we brought, we wanted to bring, put him in like the sitting seat and everything.
thing um wanted to bring him in with the um like you know put him under the like the sitting area instead of like down there in the in the storage for the bags so you know we brought our little our dog carrier but there's a lot of rules for the play and the thing is um with these rules they're like we won't let you we the carry has to be this size the carry has to be this size and also um but it has to be big enough for your dog but it has to be this size the thing is so we bought this carrier that we thought that was good size requirement for our dog and we're like this should be good because there's enough space for him and also it seems all right so we brought it along and then everything seems fine until the manager came over and was like your carrier's too big and we're like what and they're like what kind of dog is it and they looked at it and they're like oh he's gonna be you need a smaller carrier but if you get a smaller carrier for him he's too long for it so it's not
comfortable so we cannot accept this Because whatever size, even if you get the correct carrier, the size carrier, um, he, the dog is too long for it.
Like, so, I was, obviously, my parents and I, we were so confused, eh, because we were like, but this is, this is a normal carrier that we bought in Ikea, like,
Yeah, the dog was too long because he was a weiner dog.
So we bought like anything shorter because the carrier was just too long.
So we bought everything shorter.
He will not be able to like stand in it.
Like he won't be able to like stand stretched out in it because he's just too long.
So they're like, um, so then we had that.
the the cabin the cabin so so they're like you have to we you have to go out and buy a those like the metal the candle we have to put our dog like we were trying to avoid putting our dog in the baggage storage because like you know we don't know how he's like we we were scared i was gonna give him trauma because like i assume it's gonna be really cold and really loud so we wanted to go small dog.
So we wanted to go with the carrier option.
And they were like, yeah, we sold out of kennels.
So you're going to have to go out to New Year's pet store and buy a kennel for him.
It doesn't matter what size, as long as he's comfortable.
So it's just like, but after all of that, we were, they're like, okay, everything's fine.
You can check in now.
And this was a night flight okay for those who don't know in in the um in the uh bubu bubu the the security sector they close at around i think like they close at night so i don't remember it was like 11 so long ago i don't remember it was like 11 30 or 10 30.
so the thing is i think it was 11 30.
so It doesn't matter if, like, you know, the flight is, like, 12.
Oh, I think it's 10.30.
I think it's 10.30.
Because, so they're like, it doesn't matter if your flight is, like, midnight or anything.
It doesn't matter.
Like, the security closes at 10.30.
So you have to get past it before 10.30.
So, so, I was like, I was like, oh, we're all so early.
be able to make it in time and also grab dinner i'm so hungry
so so we're like you know an hour plus early and i was like yippee we're gonna grab dinner and then we you know we had to do a lot like whoever if any to anyone that has ever um shift their pet in a kennel um on a plane trip uh never have hope so key anyway um little little turkey knows she was not about to get there so um um so anyway um no it was like an hour before 10 30.
it was more than an hour before 10 30 So, you know, we got, we checked everything in, our baggage and everything.
And then, um, and then, you know, we had got all the tags for the dog, for the kennel stuff.
Like, oh, there was so much stuff.
You had, like, tags and, like, um, wires and stuff like that.
You had to lock it.
All the cages and everything, all these stickers.
And then they're like, wait right here.
You got to wait for a person to help you bring your dog through security.
We were like, me and my family were like, okay.
So we waited.
And we waited.
And then the lady, or sorry, the man, that was like, you know, the flight, I don't know what they're called.
The people that were helping you check in baggage people were like making calls and everything.
Because the thing is, the dog, needs to go through their own form of security before they are able to go through to the plane.
But we had to be there.
So we waited.
And then 30 minutes passed.
The flight attendant, the, the, the, isn't flight attendant, like they were the ones that check in your, your tickets and your luggage.
They're like, they made another call.
It's like, where are you?
You know, like, where are you?
So then we're like, Oh, and then finally, a guy pushing cart came over.
Yeah, they need to ask my dog some questions.
They want to know, where is he going?
Like, why are you going there?
Yeah, so the airline, sorry, sorry.
So then, you know, a guy came over with a cart and he was like, he's like, all right, we're here.
We're here.
So we're like, where do we go?
Yeah, they're like, okay, so you have to take your dog over there, like pointing vaguely.
So we were so confused.
My family and I were so confused.
by the way like you know there is 30 minutes have passed by then so we were very confused we're like okay um and then um okay we're gonna stop the story here because i need to blow my nose give me a second i don't have tissue right oh wait i do never mind jk i just gotta mute myself sorry cliffhanger does this dog does this dog have any bombs but that's the thing that's what the security is for they want to check the kennel if there's fucking bombs or drugs hidden in his fucking blankets so what the fuck the dog is doing the dog is the bomb so anyway um that was the whole point anyway so it's my dog a terrorist so um um anyway so we're confused me my family and the cart pusher we're so confused because i don't fucking know why he doesn't know where to go because we assumed that he knew where to go just because like you know it's his job like the the airline staff literally called him over to take our dog to wherever he's supposed to go so we're just standing here and then the security
line people like the security officers that deal with the line for the security went up to us and was like um you guys got a hurry um because um security closes at uh 10 30 and you won't be able to enter like enter through the gates after that so obviously we were like panicking because um there was 30 minutes left before security closes so we're like where the fuck do we go and then one of the one guy one of the securities the
oversized baggages or like and like to put bags through the check-in badge came over and was like you pointing to the guy pushing the car you you need to go all underground and then around and it's through this door so you can go through the staff door with the dog oh no you have to go through here so we can get you checked out out um and you have to go through all the way from the underground staff door yeah it's a maze apparently and then and through that door through this door to come to security um and then uh he didn't have to bring the dog but he the staff had to do that because it's part of like security to make sure the staff doesn't carry anything like to make sure the staff also isn't hiding anything dangerous so and then the staff was like what do you mean that's not how we do it and then the security guy was like no that's how our airport has done this this always so i don't know and then like the attendant the airline attendant came over and was like no that's not how we
do it i don't understand that's not how we always do it and then the security guy was like no we've always done this for years i don't know why you don't know the proper protocols of how to do it because we're like why can't we just push the cart over to the security check because it was just in front of us It was literally 10 steps away.
Like, we literally, and he was like, you can bring the dog over and put the car here.
And we walked 10 steps.
Put the dog in the security check table.
And, and, um, and then later he was like, all right, now you to the staff guy, you have to go underground.
Go around here.
Take the elevator, come back up and show up from this door.
door and then we can do the security check on the dog and then me and my family just stood there and waited for this one guy to show up from that one door and then the security guy was like it's protocol like you have to do it we've done this is how we do all our pet checks I'm like why does he have to go through some fucking hunger game trials like he doesn't even like we don't even know this man like he just works for the airline like I don't know this guy like
so okay for this let me see if I can draw this out like so I and then like It's just airport bureaucracy
Okay Okay Alright And then Okay I'm gonna draw this out It's gonna be really bad And then And then there's And then Man The security man
okay so okay so let me draw this out so okay I don't know if it makes sense at all but basically all right let me grab the picture okay So, there's a dog, there's me and my family, there's a security man, and the staff guy has to come out from this door,
and he will not accept anything else.
He cannot come from the side.
He cannot show up, you know, through the regular people area.
He has to show up from this door, and only this door.
So, the thing is, to get to this door, let me draw another, like, picture for you guys.
So, is that this, okay, okay, wait, wait, wait, this is the door.
He had, there's, like, an underground system.
He has to go through an elevator.
He takes an elevator, L, and it goes straight down, and then there's, like,
The door.
From what he was explaining.
Okay.
And then.
Second.
First elevator.
There you go.
He has to go through.
First elevator.
And then.
second elevator second and then this is the dog sorry i'm not drawing anything yet all right there you go i'm not showing anything yet okay here you go it's like i kind of sometimes i hate the bureaucracy and how backwards everything is all right so here's another picture
So, to illustrate, to illustrate this, he has to go through, he could, you know, he could just walk to the, there, and then we're all here.
But the thing is he has to take the first elevator and then go through this long maze and then go to the second elevator.
And then, cause he has to go through security.
Sorry, there's security right here.
Okay, sorry, let me draw like red, like beep, beep, beep, beep, security.
Security.
There you go.
So,
yeah, it's like the Disney tunnels.
So, he's got to do his own security right here.
And it's like, you know, first elevator, second, and then security down here.
And then, that's not us, by the way.
It's the staff member.
Like, and it takes a second elevator to go through this door, this door right here, while we're all waiting.
So it was like, you know, white rabbit tapping the clock.
Tick tock, tick tock.
Like, when it...
so we waited and we waited and then we're like where the fuck is this guy like the security guy was like don't worry he'll show up soon like he'll show up soon don't worry we've done this many times he'll show up and my parents and i we waited
10 minutes passed.
Another five minutes passed.
Soon, there was 10 minutes till 10.30.
It was 10.20.
And the guy has yet to show up.
And then...
And then, one of the ladies at the other security booth came up to us and was like, He came back.
He didn't know where to go.
And he came back.
And we were like, what?
What do you mean?
He came back up.
So...
There were five minutes left.
and the security guy was like it was like okay let me get the flight attendant to stay on standby because like the thing is while we were waiting he was like i'll just do the security check now and then all we have to do is wait for him to show up and we can drop the dog in the cart and he can take it to the plane so we're like okay so he was just literally you know like i don't it wasn't even that complicated of the security check like all he had to do was just pat the bed to make sure we didn't fucking sneak in he he wasn't even touching the dog he didn't care if the dog had a goddamn bomb or drugs up his ass he was drugs was not in the bed.
That's it.
It's up.
Just patting the bed and making sure.
It was like, you know, we were like, hold your dog.
And we're like, okay.
And then he was just patting the bed and everything.
And it was done in like three minutes.
Like three to five minutes.
He didn't care if the dog had anything.
Just as long as it's not in the bed or in the kennel.
And then we put the dog back into the kennel and then we're just waiting for the security waiting for the staff guy to push our dog through like the security area to the play and then when we realize we're five minutes left um the security guy was like okay we're gonna get the we're i'm going to a flight attendant and like he's just gonna stand there and wait for you guys because like protocol wise thank god he finally fucking broke protocol because he was like yeah no you just you sorry i think it was 11 30 by the way it was definitely it was 11 30 it was not 10 30 because i feel like 10 30 the restaurants will still be open.
But it was like, and then he's like, you stand there and wait where the staff got to show up so the family can go through security.
And we managed to go through, we were the last people.
And literally, it was three minutes left till closing.
We were literally the last people that went through security.
And we did not get dinner because everything was closed.
So little Doki, so bright, hopeful, and did not eat anything for dinner because all she was thinking about was, I can't wait to get some food inside.
Because I was like, Mama, can we get white spot?
Because like, there's white spot right now.
Can we get a white spot before we check in?
then mama was like don't worry we can eat inside the terminal i was like okay because we passed by a white spot i was like mama there's a white spot in the in the airport can i grab white i'm so hungry can i grab a white spot
i'm so sorry little turkey
Yeah, so Poor little Yeah, like, yippee I can win the tournament The only meal That sad child ever eaten And for turtles is Disappointment, red tape And society on the side Patchy, resty, thank you for super chat, thank you, thank you You know what was the weirdest part I was like So we got finally got through security and everything.
I was like, mama, there's a vending machine.
I'm so thirsty.
Do you think we can get to the vending machine and get some water and some snacks, mama?
And then mama and papa was like, let's head to our gate first.
Let's head to our gate first before there's vending machines there.
So, we'll get there first, okay?
And then we'll get to grab you the water and the snacks.
I was like, okay.
And then we get to our gate.
And I looked around and I was like, Mama, where are the vending machines?
Where's the vending machine, mama?
Wait.
Wait a minute.
So, yeah.
So, so, girl, and then Mama and Papa were like, don't worry, there's food in the airplane.
We can get food in the airplane.
And I was like, okay.
Now we're in the plane.
I was like, Mama, I'm so.
hungry do they have food I want to eat some I want to eat some food I don't want I don't want snacks I want food you know I didn't know a savory I don't have to say savory food because like I'm a fucking cat and then and then they're like yeah well that's the flight attendant and the flight attendant came over here and I was like do you have Mr. Tennant do you have I don't know I'm like so southern as a kid I don't know why I'm southern I'm like Mr. Tennant do you have food on the plane and Tennant was like oh yes we have pretzels I was like oh I was like Oh Oh
Oh you have like Real food And then The flight attendant Was like Oh yes we're gonna be serving Um breakfast in Um In like Four hours You know, tiny, tiny, hungry, don't you?
Was like, mama.
Mama.
Wait.
I'm so hungry.
I guess I'll take the press solicit and even I by the way guys I don't like pretzels.
I never liked them.
I just, I don't like the taste of pretzels.
It's just so bland.
So I had pretzels.
I had pretzels and then I waited four hours.
for breakfast especially no you don't understand airplane pretzels ain't it guys airport airplane pretzels ain't it i could have got white spot i could have got white spot instead no it's a hard airport pretzels too it ain't it it's not good like deal with airplane food uh the swordsman thank you the super chat thank you thank you um paturetsu thank you with super chat thank you thank you the only meal that side child will ever eat in airport terminals is disappointment red tape and society on the side how you have here thank you with super chat thank you thank you thank you in Puerto Rico it's past your bag through agricultural check then drop off your packs then go through TSA thank you with super chat thank you thank you oh psycho they use super chat they can thank you one hour about marvel rivals 30 minutes about canadian bank and now little dokey trauma that's my sad oh she thank you for the super chat thank you thank you this is my free therapy session this is cheaper than
therapy i just trauma dump you guys and now you guys know why i'm the way i am like now you're like why is she always laughing and i'm just like i'm sorry you know it's like the it's like i'm sorry i i all i can do is laugh through this trauma like oh that's all i can do like um patra said thank you for the super chat Thank you,
thank you.
They'll have to keep from crying.
Exactly.
We're talking rogo, we're talking real genuine soft-baked pretzels.
Were they unsalted?
Was there no sauce?
Was it literally a hard-baked no salt?
The airplane way.
That's how traumatic it was.
The fact that I remember what the fuck these pretzels taste like.
You do not understand.
I was so hungry.
I...
little dokey only had lunch and then she had to take a fucking night flight past her bedtime and I was promised food I was like mama can I go to white spot couldn't get my little pirate ship my pirate ship nuckies for those who don't know white spot is like white spot is like a family canadian restaurant and like they have a kids meal where it's literally a pirate ship and then they give you dino nuggets and i couldn't have my dino nuggets i've been through so much no pirate ship dino nuggets um yeah thank you for super chat thank you thank you from a young age Dogey,
Rod Dog, Airplane Travel.
That's my OG.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The worst part.
That flight, that flight I had to take, the plane did not have a screen.
No screens at all.
No TV screen in front of me.
No TV screen coming out from the plane on the top.
I am true raw dog moment there you know and as a child that is not how you want to go that's not how you want to go no name thank you a super chat thank you thank you suffering builds character I have so much character I that's why I have such a big personality nothing yeah nothing but turbulence yeah so I feel like this was like all trauma it's just it's just it's just trauma all the ways I'm sorry my hangout session is my free therapy session it really is
current and past dokey yeah yeah oh but anyway that's how fucked Canadian bureaucracy is um I mean I told you guys the vet stories like that shit is wild the hoops I have to jump through to like get my dog prescription and everything I think by the way I recently learned that Canadian I thought,
I thought guys, I thought Canadian Amazon, oh, oh my gosh okay, so I found out the difference between like Canadian Amazon and American Amazon so like one of my friends they were asking me about like the dog food that I have to like the special diet and they're like,
oh, what kind of like dog because they were planning on putting their dog on a special diet as well so they were like asking what brand it was it was like oh um it's hills um that's the brand i use and my dog is on kidney care and then they're like oh yeah i'm gonna try and order it because i was like you can just order it off of amazon because that's what i do and they're like oh okay so they try to order it off of amazon and then they're like wait it says i need like a prescription from my vet i was like what the fuck you know like what do you mean so apparently special diets for dogs or cats in america um your vet has to prescribe it to you but in canada they don't fucking care just order it off of that yeah yeah so like you have to like grab a special number from your vet to like be given permission to order like special food for your pets in america but in canada i literally find the food and then i order it off of amazon i get it in one to two days because our food there's no
it's not a prescription you know it's just like recommended they're like yeah we recommend you get this dog food and then like i just order it like it's yeah it's you can't just and that's like it's so weird i was like what like I should just buy it off of Amazon it comes in in one in two days like it's so but the thing is it's so weird it's so weird like there's like certain things you can't just order off of Amazon Canada and certain things you can apparently in America it's like so weird
Because in Canada, there are like, you know, medication and, and like, not like, you know, bad drugs, but like, medication drugs that you have to be prescribed on, or you have to prescribe to get it.
And, like, you can't get off the counter or anything.
Like, you actually have to ask the, you have to ask the pharmacist to, like, grab, like, some sort of...
certain medications or some certain like special drugs monitor drugs or anything like um from the pharmacist to be able to purchase it because it's all like locked like behind counter but then i found out um because like one time similar story um they're asking me about a certain medication i forgot what it was i was like oh yeah yeah i can um yeah you can just grab that um you can have you get it like uh uh you have to ask the pharmacist uh to be able to or get it prescribed and you're like oh i could just order it off of amazon i was like what
what do you mean by that yeah see comes in like one or two days i just it's just on amazon i was like what the do you mean i have to walk to the pharmacy and ask if they have it in stock It's at the pharmacy I was like, what do you mean you can just order it online?
Yeah, so it was like, yeah, apparently what was it melatonin for melatonin in Canada You can't just Amazon order melatonin You have to you have to get that like because you know you have to ask the pharmacist like to be like oh, yeah I would like to have some But like in America
you can just Amazon order it
you don't need a prescription you just have to go to the pharmacy and like you have to go to the pharmacy and ask for it but because it's off the counter it's not on the counter you have to ask for it and be like um can I get some melatonin and they're like yeah yeah
now off the shelf i remember before it was like you have to go to the pharmacy you have to like just be like can i have like melatonin uh i guess i guess we passed the law and be like you can do it now but there are some medications that like i don't remember which one it was i don't remember which medication it was because like it was a while ago and they're like no i'm just ordering off of amazon i was like what the do you mean i have to fucking i was like i have to walk to the Like,
what do you mean?
You can just order it online.
Yeah.
Um.
So, so like, it's fucking, I hate Canada bureaucracy, but like, sometimes it's good.
Sometimes, we have some positives.
Like, you know, we can, at least we can order.
At least we can order dog food online.
Like, you think Like, this is the thing I don't understand.
We need a prescription.
Like, in America, you need a prescription for dog food.
But, like, who the fuck cares about human medication?
Who the fuck cares about human medication?
Like, it's just...
No, but the thing is, yes, you can order dog food online.
But, like, it has to be prescribed.
Like, the special diet ones.
The special diet ones, it has to...
You have to get your vet to like prescribe you the special food.
But in Canada, you don't do that.
You just fucking order it online.
Like, like the vet just recommends you the food.
And then literally on Amazon, two to three days, it's over.
Like I don't have to give them any information.
It just arrives.
But in America, it's like you have to jump through so many hoops to give your dog special food.
But then like if you want to order like medication or like any special type of drugs for like, you know Like the actual not the illegal ones the legal ones The pharmaceutical drugs like you could just order that off of Amazon who the fuck cares like
Fuck cares yeah Yeah, thank you the super chat.
Thank you.
TSB collab tomorrow.
Oh, it's not tomorrow.
I think it's a it's the day after tomorrow unless you're like uh so it's it's on it's on thursday yeah it's on thursday i think it was super chat thank you thank you what's the story behind the name um for those who've never heard of tsb um the team it's team snake bite um so the name is team snake bite and the team name came from uh it was part of an apex tournament and um it was based we had other names at first there was other names and then um we i asked a very important question because i used to ask this question a lot to my homies because i want to know if they're a true homie or not you know like this is the only question this is a question that you ask people to know if they're a bro or not if they're a real homie and it's basically like if a snake fit your dick would you would you suck the poison out of the dick like Or let your homie die.
So, obviously, this is like the only question you ask.
Like, it's the ultimate vibe check, you know?
It's the ultimate bro check to see if, like, he's a real homie or not.
So, I asked that question.
And then I was like, we were like, we were brainstorming names before.
And I'm like, we were like having a huge debate and everything.
wouldn't do it and he still wouldn't it's been years and he still wouldn't save a homie he was like I fucking let that guy die he's like I ain't sucking poison out like it is like fuck that shit I was like bro that didn't cool man and then I was like guys what do we call ourselves team snake bite
so so so after we were arguing for like an hour straight about whether or not like he was like like about why he should do it and then we were talking about like coffee pasta and then the chat started spamming like do not wallow tsp is here to swallow if he's low then you gotta blow for a wind to keep you gotta go deep our throats will get till we get the bag so like when we're the tournament people will start like spamming this to cheer for us on like broadcasts and stuff because you know that's what people do back then like you know like copy pasta like oh my gosh there was like so like you know in esports if you guys ever watch esports people would make like dumb ass copy pastas but they're so fucking clever there's so many like clever shit i don't remember does anyone remember like the classic esport copy pastas that people used to do when they're cheering for their teams i can't remember them on the top of my head but we were like like replicating that because like you know that
brings team like that brings like people that cheer for like you know when they want cheer for their team um people would start chanting these things out so we're like oh we should we should make one for our team you know so yeah like people can spam that like to um spam this yeah spam this pine to help c9 like shit like that like
yeah spam this noodle to help skedoodle like people would spam that in esports so like in like esport tournaments like in any game like league counter strike overwatch like shit like that so we're like oh my god guys we should do something similar for our team like so to bring up like team spirit for like people who want to cheer for us so that's where tsb came from it was like one of the most the one of and then the thing is by calling us tsb um It was a Japanese tournament.
Because we called ourselves TSB.
We didn't call ourselves Team Snake Bite.
We just put TSB.
So the Japanese viewers and the Japanese commentators did not know the context behind our names.
It's so...
They don't know why the fuck we called ourselves TSB.
Because we gave zero context.
Because we didn't explain it.
like because we were just called TSB so they're like oh TSB TSB you know so there was like no actual context so people were like oh it's so it's so say so it's so normal but the English speaking side knows the real story they know why we were called TSB in the true context so um the Japanese side didn't know why they just thought it was all tsb you know just tsb like little do they know yeah one of the commenters praising how cool the name was because it sounded cool you know tsb tsb but then we're actually called team snake bite because we're like will you suck your your would you suck the poison out of your homie's dick like it's like sweet summer child You don't know the real context.
Do they know?
They didn't know.
So, that's the context of TSB.
It was honestly one of the greatest group names I've ever came up with.
Dude, bear.
Chat came up with it, but I stole it and took credit.
Because I was like, I looked at chat.
And someone was like, you should call yourself Team Snake Fight.
I was like, oh my God, guys, we should call ourselves Team Snake Fight.
I don't even know which chatter said that, too.
The credit's mine, though.
Like, I saw it in chat.
Didn't remember the name.
And I was like, guys, I got a great name for us.
We should call ourselves Team Snake Fight.
Like, it did came from my chat, though.
So I was like, yoink.
I demand royalties like you still owe us a blend no I don't know what you're talking about Patrasu they give me the Hakka soup but thank you thank you winners change history it's okay it's because you guys are a hive mind and I'm the hive
anyway guys anyway guys I think this is a good time to end I'm not here to avoid anything But I think this is a good time to call it here.
I hope you guys had a great time hanging out with me.
Oh my gosh, we yapped for so long.
That was fun yapping session today.
Fun hangout session, everyone.
But anyway, guys, thank you all for hanging out with me today.
I hope you guys have a fun time to hang out with me.
Have you guys enjoyed my trauma dump today, too?
I always love talking to all you guys.
I always vibe a lot with everyone.
um it's always fun hanging out and you know i always appreciate you dragons anyways oh yeah before i go before i go please check out my controller it really does help a lot if you support and pre-order the um the void gaming controller wait give me a sec i gotta find it though let me find the png real quick i have so many dumb things downloaded on my I don't know where it is.
Give me a sec, guys.
Let me find... Wait, what?
Did I not... Oh, no.
Did I...
Where did I save it?
When did... Oh, my God.
There's so many things that I save.
Wait, sort by date modify.
I thought I have a PNG of this.
Oh, wait.
It's because it's in my thumbnail.
Sorry.
I'm a little... I'm a little cuckoo today.
Oh.
Where is it?
Wait, guys.
Don't go yet.
Don't go!
I have to share.
Guys, please don't go.
I thought, oh, there it is.
I found it.
All right, there you go.
The Doki Bird Controller.
Guys, please, we have a week and a half left to pre-order it before it's gone.
So please, pre-order.
Yeah, pre-order your very own Doki Bird Controller.
If we get enough orders, we might be able to do other types of controllers.
Wink, wink, wink, wink.
Okay, I'd say wink, but I'm not winking.
wink wink wink wink all right here let me so yes please please pre-order this controller really does help me out a lot also helps out our collab partner here as well so yeah please feel free to pre-order this it really does help out a lot you know if this does well we'll have more opportunities in the future for more cool merch so please we have a week and a half left so place your orders before it's gone yeah hey guys as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that blood flowing and you still for me head to bed cause you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye